pub
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur la patinoire de garmisch en
allemagne
les vice-champions du monde marica
caylus et yogan bamber nous donne un
aperçu de ce qu'est le patinage moderne
moderne à ce point que marica et yogen
se met au goût du jour ils ont adapté le
rock'n'roll alors figure de patinage
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
bah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors là
ce serait peut-être moins dangereux de
danser le rock and roll comme tout le
monde sur un parquet ciré et ainsi marie
car ne resterait pas de prendre froid
hamer et phil devant l'ecosse l'équipe
de france de rugby a prouvé qu'elle a
peut-être encore une chance cette année
de remporter le tournoi des six nations
le début du match est un grand festival
offensif défense 26 minutes de jeu
le trois quarts centre bouquet après une
course de 50 mètres passe à meyer qui
marque le plus bel essai de la partie
entre les poteaux qui se transporte
facilement gagné
après quelques phases de jeu confuses
bouquet encore lui perce une nouvelle
fois et c'est l'ailier méric qui ajoute
trois points à l'actif de son équipe
[Applaudissements]
dépenser bousculer les écossais il
ajoute un troisième essai signé par leur
capitaine françois moncla 13 0 pour les
écossais c'est un désastre ce désastre
finalement sera transformée en défaite
honorable
l'équipe de france à un joueur blessé
les écossais sentent que c'est le moment
d'attaquer ce match fini par marquer
pour son équipe 1 essai transformé
[Applaudissements]
cet essai sera suivie d'un coup franc
qui ramène la marque à 13 à 8 les
français sont pressés près de la ligne
de but mais ils tiendront presque
jusqu'au bout
[Applaudissements]
et finalement les écossais frise
l'égalisation par un dernier essai à
huit minutes de la fin du match que
gagne la france par 13 ans
sa vie
six amateurs au mètre carré cent vingt
peintres célèbres trois commissaires
priseurs de grand renom
la collection d'art la plus éphémère
puisqu'elle n'aura duré que le temps
d'être réunies pour être dispersées au
feu des enchères
il est vrai que c'était pour les
sinistrés de fréjus 75,78 virent ainsi
aura-t-on vu à la galerie charpentier
autour des chagall des buffets des miros
des dalits des brap offerts par leurs
auteurs voltige et en franc lourd des
chiffres dans le total dépasse le
million soit 100 millions de francs
léger le plus coté fut naturellement
picasso
cent cinquante mille à 15 millions
d'hier une belle vente et une bonne
action avenue paul doumer
71 le mur derrière lequel il se passe
quelque chose
et dehors par moins cinq il faut avoir
du courage c'est sans doute pourquoi un
reporter et photographe sont allées chez
le bistrot du coin assister à la
conférence de presse que leur a faite
jacques charrier à l'occasion de la
naissance de son fils nicolas
[Musique]
nouvelle qui si elle ne fait pas pas
mais les chancelleries n'en a pas mois
pour l'édification des foules mobilisées
tout le journalisme de chat pensez donc
le bébé de bb à montereau les crises de
france vient de réaliser une performance
stupéfiante en édifiant en moins de deux
ans la plus moderne des centrales
électriques
cette centrale est apte à fonctionner au
charbon dont l'acheminement est assurée
automatiquement jusqu'au chaudière
[Musique]
mais son originalité est d'être la
première à utiliser également le gaz de
lacq comme combustible elle peut en
outre fonctionner à la fois au gaz et au
charbon
[Musique]
tout est automatique depuis la mise en
service des brûlures dont l'action est
suivie sur des écrans de télévision
jusqu'aux opérations de dépoussiérage
qui permettent de les expulser dans
l'atmosphère qu'une simple vapeur d'eau
[Musique]
dans cet immense usine aucune activité
humaine puisque tout est télécommandé
d'un double poste central ou deux hommes
seulement assure la surveillance et le
contrôle
[Applaudissements]
la nouvelle centrale de montereau est un
modèle du genre
sa puissance atteindra un million de
kilowatts en même temps pas progrès
révolutionnaires elles constituent un
lapointe dont on peut souligner
l'importance pour l'alimentation en
courant électrique de la région
parisienne
on a déjà connu la croix gamme it une
maladie à fanfare et attrapes haut mais
on a vu aussi où elle menait la maladie
débute une démangeaison l'antisémitisme
tout apparaît la croix gammée
malheur aux juifs on a vu cela voué à
l'exécration livré à la vindicte
publique il ne tardait pas à être
ramassées comme du bétail pour être
transporté on sait tous
on sait comment les a retrouvés on sait
oui ceux qui ont vécu cette époque mais
les autres mais ce qui avait 5 ans en ce
temps là le savent ils eux nous nous
avons vu l'affreuse étoile jaune
désigner le juif à toutes les injures et
l'étoile jaune c'était toujours un
préambule aux camps de la mort mais
combien qui ont grandi n'ont jamais su
ce que contenaient les camps de la mort
ce qu'eisenhower aujourd'hui président
des états unis a pu voir en les ouvrant
en 45 sous le signe de la croix gammée
c'était la trique le fouet la masse
comme à l'abattoir tout cela pour finir
au four crématoire que le nazisme
n'avait pas bâti assez nombreux pour
absorber son contingent quotidien de
cadavres
on
[Musique]
il ya parmi nous des enfants qui n'ont
pas vu ces images et des grands qui les
ont oubliées ces morts vivants
ouvert de vermine qu'il ramenait au
grand jour de la liberté que la maladie
la firme it et où la folie
[Musique]
c'est homme tatoué d'un numéro dont la
peau tannée pouvait servir à leur
tortionnaire pour fabriquer des reliures
ou des abat jour
c'est à ceux qui ne savent pas ou qui ne
savent plus qu'il faut dire c'est ça que
vous appelez quand vous tracer une croix
gammée
ce signe c'est l'appel à cette odeur de
charnier qui reste collé à la peau du
nazisme
vous voulez jouer avec la croix gamme it
regarder des millions d'âmes en sont
morts est mort de quelle façon vous
voulez recommencer vous êtes fous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]